good examples
it's a nice production this is Anthony
from Caltech so thanks a lot with
organizers for making making this lovely
events and thank you all for being here
in this morning
are we talking about the line of work
that's still rapidly changing
um we hope only put out one related
paper yet but more it's going to come
so let's now enjoy give sampling okay
and before I begin I'll ask the audience
so how many of you have done a physics
experiment before
that's quite a lot how much of you
identify yourself as physicists
yeah that I think that's what I expected
um so the reason why I'm asking is
because this topic is really between
physics and computer science
it's there are lots of basically the
same idea but it was spoken in a very
different language and hopefully um to
bridge the gap between this very
different communities and partly I
believe the reason why this topic has
been kind of almost ignored for a long
time is because
coming to you haven't really quite talk
together
let's get started
the main task of interest is concave
sampling
they're given a quantum hamiltonian
and a quantum computer
fully for tolerant and your task is to
prepare the keep State on your Quantum
memory
this is perfectly well defined
on a gift set here it's a Quantum States
that's a incoherent mixture
of the energy basis States
they are weighted according to the
boltzmann weight which is exponential
minus beta e
for who are more familiar with physics
this is something that people talk about
every day
but even you're from computer science
this is something you can write down and
then start reasoning about this object
to get more sense of what this is doing
if you make beta really large so you see
this exponential is going to be very
small it means that you'll kill all
excited States so it's basically in the
ground state
and if B times zero it means that you
kind of treat all the energies equally
you end up getting a Max Linux state
should be no surprise here
um so now we already find a problem then
we can just move on and discuss as a
theorist the difficulty or it's an
algorithm to achieve this task
however I know there are some industry
activity around Quantum Computing so I
want to give a motivation from those
people here
so apparently um if you ask your
industry colleagues or people who try
who now actively trying to build a
chronic computer they're looking for a
killer app
you know this will keep their funding
going and also make them
earn money
and the thing that seems closest maybe
not everyone agree but it seems lots of
people would think the second is to do
column simulation
at least that's my exposure
um
and the concentration is a fairly
well-defined task we all know it's
pretty useful because we have been doing
simulation upon the system every day
mainly now is through classical
computers
but now you want to do it in the
computer because everything is quantum
and it's a quantum computer supposedly
to be a very nice thing to do
example usage could be for example to
understand the growing energy of some
molecules you can put any molecule here
does molecule got to have some
hamiltonian and you can just put that
into a quantum computer you want to
understand its properties
and people this is um this common
simulation problem have been conceived
for a very long time there are lots of
progress perhaps the most mature field
income in Quantum algorithms
and you can imagine there are several
things you might need to do you might
need to prepare in neutral States in
this case the ground state
or in many cases the thermostates
you better want to know how to do this
hamiltonian simulation
and then do some measurements
and then you can use all these things in
all kinds of combinations
um but this is basically the building
blocks
and as of today
um
people are still very boggled by the
first one state preparation
to be very practical if you look at this
paper put out by companies
it might be missing out some of them at
this account a few years ago
um
the state preparation part has been a
big mystery
so we don't know how expensive this one
is
and this constant Factor Could Just Kill
the whole industry right if the concept
is a million then well it's not likely
you're going to run it
oh the like how expensive this task is
so they're just like some a known factor
I think called DotA and the Delta we
don't know how big it is
like the algorithm depends on a known
Factor
how expensive this task is
I suppose you want to achieve that task
but there are various algorithms to do
state preparation you just go for a big
molecules it's not very clear how to how
expensive that is
for a simple one I don't know what's
happening but for bigger one that you
actually care
it's all good
okay so um so what's interesting here is
that the state preparation problem is
actually almost at Heart of quantum
computation a lot of various like Rich
landscape and Theory that's coming out
of this
so let me let me I'll just ask as a
computer scientist how hard is it um to
prepare low energy states
right so your gut feeling from
complexity is that this problem seems
really really difficult
and the worst case this is lies in this
complexity class here mates or at least
as hard as that
and this is nothing not a good thing to
tell investor right if you say well
hello we're going to build a quantum
computer to solve this problem that our
problem our computer cannot solve
so this is kind of pessimistic
however if you now ask
um different
um disciplines or people from different
disciplines such as computational people
they would say that well actually this
task is could be quite easy there are
lots of people um implementing highly
efficient heuristic classical algorithms
that solve chemistry problems Material
Science problem it seems to work very
well
so the hardness of foreign
accuracy I think still those still not
very clear but I think indeed like if
you increase if you increase Precision
it does get harder I think people do get
that in
but for constant Precision I I don't
think it's it's okay
but it doesn't get easier
things to be so personal
okay
also you see that on the landscape
there's two kind of bad things happening
either the problem just get too hard to
even for quantum computers
or it gets too easy that even classical
computer can solve it
which is which is a constant projection
on the state yes
information with with finally you know
with a small percentage
so so basically to France question uh if
the homogeneous Gap this is
that the approximation could be very bad
still as hard as hard as regarding about
it yeah
thank you
just keep going
um so to make the story continue um okay
so what we want to do here is to find
something here
something that's
quantly easy and classical guitar
and does anyone has a candidate
hamiltonian that thinks they think that
fits into this this part
it's working oh maybe I think that's
like
but yeah I think the community can
um
yes
um but those are those problems that you
want to run in your common computer then
sell it here you know customers
all right so yes also
um and find two examples maybe you can
embed if you could even be cooked into
here
um but are they kind of more physical
physically reasonable hamiltonian they
have this property maybe it's srk model
or maybe maybe something else
thank you
um
there you see that there's there's two
things that you want is terrify both of
them are pretty difficult um hardness is
always hard to prove as we we know
um but if you want to prove Quantum
easiness it's actually not impossible
because all you need to do is to give
the algorithm
and then you very concretely know
yourself the problem at least the
quantum agents
and that's the route we're going to do
today is to think about new algorithms
that potentially leads to a lot of cases
of quantity easy low energy problems
to make the story continue
um sorry I'm going to ask physicists is
the same question so just ask your
industry or your lab colleagues how hard
is it to prepare low energy state in
your lab
this is what they're going to tell you
they're going to just go to show you
their dilution fridge and say that I do
this every day
right so physics or thermodynamics just
tells you if you just couple your system
to a pass no matter what material it is
if you just put it in your path
you push a button and you get a give
space or sometimes you get a ground
States
so it seems that if this is true
then we have a very strong
um kind of empirical evidence that lots
of States got to be quantumly easy
right because nature all these bad it's
got to become mechanical if you simulate
the whole thing you can prepare the give
state
it is all heuristic but I would like to
use this as just like an empirical um
just location
um or the motif of this talk because
what we're going to do today is to
take the extract the essence of this
phenomena and to cook up the content
algorithm that captures this effect
so we're going to do today
um is to propose the algorithm that
captures the previous slide I don't have
a good name for the algorithm yet I just
call it Monte Carlo Quantum algorithms
the algorithm you're about to see
um will be very close closely related or
heavy inspired by the idea of cooling
and physics
no not actually talk about any physical
things here because I guess you guys
don't care about this part
um but what's interesting here is that
we have like almost complementary almost
um a view of the same subject from
classical Monte Carlo
so for computer scientists you can
understand the algorithm of Interest
today
is a Content version of classical Monte
Carlo
surprisingly two things is not existing
so we kind of present kind of
the dismissing algorithm in the quantum
world
historically classical Monte Carlo has
been extremely useful it's very simple
to use at the same time very robust you
can apply to all all the cases you want
initially you started out being a
physics simulation um
algorithms people use it to study icing
models
but then
um throughout the the past decades it
has evolved into like all powerful
algorithm I can apply it to optimization
constraints as a fine problem machine
learning also the stuff
um
and here I just want to use this kind of
usefulness of Monica to argue that the
thing we're going to talk about today
could likely inherit lots of the
properties
I mean if basically
yes yes
um so
um
is it the same topic
um we recently realized there's some
assumption that since
questionable and we can in contact with
them so
yeah
and we also redo the whole thing
completely yeah so I'll talk about some
of the reason why
why we like we do the whole thing
right um to begin to set up stage for
the quantum version start with the
classical one
this is all textbook material which is
very quickly review it
part of time Monte Carlo often called
mcmc is the following idea
you want to implement a markup chain
it's a stochastic Matrix such that if
you repeatedly invoke it you take
product of it converts to the Gibbs Gibb
state
in particular here's a checklist you
want to go through to make sure that
it's actually working
so first you must be officially
implementable
if you want to officially implement this
Matrix M on your on your randomized
algorithm
and second you want to keep state to be
stationary
next point of this Matrix
and with the first two you can already
run this algorithm
and just wait how long but you might not
know how long it's going to converge but
you can wait and can wait long enough
maybe it works
only stationary state or unnecessarily
no okay yeah
it depends on what you want if you
really want to give state it better be
the unique one otherwise you might get
stuck in somewhere else
sometimes you only care about the energy
stage it doesn't require matter you just
kind of want to get attention
I guess probably the answer is it's
coming in living size but what do you
think precisely by converting rapidly
all right you can make it very formal so
you can hit decrease distance and
if iteration always it doesn't require
too many iteration for it to be close
but it depends then on the I mean
temperature because this we know has to
take accidental time but like
sufficiently low temperature yes yes so
mixing time could change a lot it
depends on all sorts of things so
converging rapidly means
cost per step and then there's this
under mixing time factor that could be
exponential
if you put some very hard problem in it
like a hard problem I mean in this case
it would be hard probably not mix
Ed excuse me I'm still muscles
because I mean I mean if you have more
stationary States there's no guarantee
that all of them
very high energy highlights of stations
because
care about that sir
oh this is a in some sense a heuristic
algorithm
I mean you run it and you see how it
works but it's a customer
listening is a core thing right and if
you can't keep it
it's something very simple to check
obviously yeah so here I was kind of
throw away those things but indeed you
want to design marker chains such as
if possible if you want to keep saying
you want to avoid those as much as
possible
and if you indeed if you choose if you
design a Markov chain probably then
those things
I had a discount
how important is reversibility are you
interested in reversible it's a very
convenient way to get the gear State
like eco-factors
but it's not always but I think a lot of
case because it's much understandable
people like to use
okay so um let me just give a very quick
example of what it looks like if you
have a 1B chain there's like four now
there's four different states
and say let's say let's try to design a
markup chain that converts the keep
State on these four states
okay battery control keep state is going
to be exponential following distribution
right exponential minus E
um and you can check that
look at if these if you pick your
transition rates exactly at least one
these numbers it does
fix a keep state
and they can ask like if I want to go
beyond this very simple example how how
do I design my markup chain without
first solving the whole problem
um
yeah so how do you do it um so let's
illustrate from from this simple model
um there's this idea called detailed
balance
um that is a very nice answers that give
you stationary State as the gifts day
this answered it doesn't always hold so
in many cases if you're designing it
it's good to have it convenient
so the idea of detail balance is to
enforce that the flow between any Q
configurations
cancel for each other at stationarity
okay so you can pictorial you cannot see
what's going on here
um you can write down some algebraic
expression that captures this
indeed if the two flows are equal then
nothing changes so keep saying must be
stationary
reiterate you can write it in the
picture of transition Matrix
and this 1D line the transition Matrix
is um tried diagonal matrix
okay
and video balance in this case just
amounts to the symmetry of this this
Matrix right so you're going to look at
these entries
here across the diagonal and you want
them to satisfy this algebraic
let's just numbered some number that
depends on the temperature
for example if beta is zero then
um these two are the same so the Matrix
is symmetric
this exactly corresponds to the
reversible markup chain
if beta is large then this is kind of
biased and it's not exactly symmetric
but they still obey some symmetry up to
this Vector okay
if you ask this detailed balance seems
to be a very delicate condition how are
you going to implement it
um
algorithmically right because you might
you might start out with some huge
configuration space that you don't if
you already know what it looks like and
how are you going to implement detailed
balance efficiently
so there's a solution a very nice idea
called rejection sampling that kind of
is what enables Monte Carlo
um
which is a rhythmic way to implement
detail balance without knowing the full
Matrix
so roughly it's just Implement detail
bands on the go it's not like you first
write down the whole Matrix and then do
something with it it's just that
whenever you see an entry
use an algorithm and that and then it
gets detail balance okay so what it's
doing here is that you start with a
symmetric markup chain
and then you just decided that you're
going to reject anything that occurs
that's
um on this lower triangle
you're just going to try to bias the
flows
and
just by sometimes rejecting one side of
the move you can kind of kill the
transition here
and then it just become weaker and if
you pick it correctly you get a
detailed balance
so let's just look at example um with
very old algorithm called Metropolis
Hasting and still being run today or
there are lots of variants with this one
that's kind of captured essence
there's a user here several things you
want to specify you want to choose a
hamiltonian so inverse temperature beta
uh and some set of jumps
right the hamiltonian could be an icing
model
um there are some parameters you just
put it in your computer
and these set of jumps could be spin
flips so it's going to change the spin
variable at each
of your lattice sites
and this are all the parameters you need
to fit into your computer
here's what the algorithm looks like you
can start with some initial States some
spin configuration
and you can randomly flip a spin
and if energy could increase or decrease
and when it decrease that's good because
you want orange States you accept the
move
If energy increase that's bad and
sometimes you have to reject the move
okay and then you have to reject it by
and doing a jump so whatever you did you
just had to undo it
kind of pretend nothing has happened
and just by doing this actually gives
you the markup chain uh if you and if
you iterate this a few times you could
get the game stick if you converge
quickly
okay
so now I'm just quickly summarize what
we have been discussing for the
classical case it will be useful to
understand what are we quantizing
on the left you have the choice of
configuration which are just classical
spins the cube state is a distribution
on a classical spins it could be a
classical hamiltonian and some setup
jumps
and what we want to do today
is to make everything content
and here's some nice suggestions I can
upgrade the spins to entangled States
these are configurations
now becomes quantum
the hamiltonian better be non-commuting
so this could be poly X and y's which
don't commute
and then now you jump since you're in on
qubits you can have xyz's
pretty intuitive
and the goal for today is to address
this this question right how do we
design algorithm that
quantize this follower that's this
classical
give something algorithms
all right so this one just example so
okay this should be black box
do you require your job
no no
it takes you because
I don't require that it takes you to
like Escape
all right so let's move on to our main
the main course of today is how we
design on these
Monte Carlo Quantum hours
so one thing you might want to do is to
is to just go to the energy basis
right so if you look at the Gibb States
and see how they differs between
classical and quantum
classical Gibson is a probably
distribution over the strings
the content one just the same
distribution but on the quantum States
so if you can see you might say well I
just upgraded the split strings to
energetic States
and just run Metropolis on on these
eigenous states whatever that means
foreign
you would upgrade your transition
probability which is this Matrix I've
been discussing
and you want to upgrade it to transition
amplitudes
all right there's amplitudes because
it's quantum
but what it means here is just to take
the jump operator a and then sandwich
with in a different energy against
States
and a square to get a probability
does that have the rejection
yeah that's another thing too yeah but
this is just prefer step so should I
think of the A's as House observators of
us feedback you apply as well yeah yeah
thank you
so a is kind of like the
um the pair like the minimum thing you
do but then to get actual cross operator
you have to kind of modify them
because every trade choice of a is not
going to have detail balance
so you have to do some rejection you
have to modify them so that it becomes
like a detailed balance
thank you
so you're going to be sending your spin
variables from you're going to be
switching signs on your spin variables
and one of the old theorems in quantum
mechanics is to do that in general you
need anti-linear operators right so your
a is actually not entirely General
because it would be a linear operator in
that form is that correct or not correct
um
why does it have to be declared why does
it become a non-leading a little
anti-linear but where does that come
from so for example if I have an
operator that flips Z X and Y to
negative
and why I believe that you need to do
that with an answer oh all right all
right so um indeed so
if you're talking about like you have
um
Z which or acts like this flip a spin
um printers
so it's not like you actually
send
like plus y to minus five and like so
there are a lot of choices of jump
operators okay
thank you
this is
Steve I mean if this is
fundamentally very different technology
exactly exactly that's why this idea
wouldn't exactly work
but this is kind of intuitive but is
this kind of the only systematic way to
try to quantize it because I mean this
creates a huge amount of support
yeah so indeed to
um to Echo with that I can say it's a
really delicate
very complex it's hard to access
um that's why initial attempts has not
been perfect
um so we'll try to do as much as
possible on this line that of course
have to technically change that
this is really a guiding place
yeah so there's lots of fun challenges
kind of if you want to go along this
route on the first one
um
is algorithmic
the challenge here is how you how are
you going to coherently reject the state
without collapsing it
right so classically you can if you want
to do rejection sampling you can just go
and then sometimes reject it you can
just undo the job
or you can even just clone a state right
you have lots of things you can do to
achieve this
um but fountainly this is not so obvious
you cannot clone the state
um you might have a very careful with
your measurements otherwise you might
collapse the stage
so this is reminiscent reminiscent of
the task or the algorithm of rewinding
that people think have still been
discussing recently
so you have to do that and it was quite
a complicated algorithm
the Second Challenge is analytic
is precisely that energy measurements is
always kind of difficult it's very
difficult to access energy against
States and same as the energy
measurements
so you can think of that whenever you're
running this markup chain your energy
estimates are going to be like uncertain
like fuzzy
and you can imagine how this is going to
change detail balance
needle balance is something that we have
lost so much and markup chain so if you
lose it we're kind of very unhappy
foreign
challenges
have been kind of
avoiding lots of previous attacks
I'll skip sampling that's kind of why
this problem is hard
okay so today's algorithm we overcome
these um these two challenges and here's
what we got
the algorithm look like this
um it's a continuous time markup chain
if you like discrete things this is
maybe not kind of entirely familiar but
this is what we constructed
we claim that our algorithm satisfied
the following criteria of the Monte
Carlo style algorithm
it is efficient in a sense that this
exponential can be implemented
efficiently
is a Content algorithm for it
and second it has the desired property
that it fixes to keep the keep state
all right so with the first two it's
very similar to the classical case and
you can now run this algorithm and on a
quantum computer and see what happens
right if it converts quickly you win
it kind of converts slowly well maybe
you have to try another algorithm
in other cases even if you don't know
the mixing time you can still write down
the cost per give sample
it's going to be a cost of implementing
this one step
um and it's going to be multiplied by
the mixing time it's like how long
you're going around it's very intuitive
what's interesting here is that all the
complexity essentially boils down to
this mixing time which seems to be a
quantity that in Quantum computation has
not been quite discussed
right so I know some of you don't like
continuous things I'll spend a slide
discussing what this continuous time
markup chain is
um you can think of it as a continuous
Quantum version of a continuous time
classical markup chain so it's like a
generator
so it's not like a discrete map or
rather it gives like tiny changes
um so you have to take the real tips
importantly it looks it has this form
um that some mathematicians has just
worked out the explicit form and look
like this it's entirely parametrized by
a set of L's
right and any of L would give a valid um
of continuous time component markup
chains
you can think of this as a continuous
version continuous version of quantum
channels so these L's are just analogs
of cross operators
but because it's continuous kind of how
to add the second term to make it face
preserving but other than it's not it's
not too different
related to The Continuous
um
is it coherence or not
um should be I mean you can make it
before
this one is usually not
yeah you're working on the density
operator you also don't understand
right you're just directly working on
the density
so there's some particles in it
so to listen to
the realization
locks yes
we don't know how to do that through
this great phase
is what you're saying
the discrete case for the contact
yes yeah that seems hard and this one
seems to be much easier
even though it was kind of scary but
somehow this is much nicer to think
about
sorry Mr what was the statement that you
can't do in the screen time that you can
continue
right so
the test is going to be skip sampling
and you can do it discreetly or
continuously
and now um I don't know how to do this
discrete one even though we know how to
do the containers sorry I'm talking just
unraveled
yeah but you're still basically working
on this guy
because I mean Metropolis you kind of
have to do this discrete rejection I
just said I don't know how to do that
still so you wouldn't call it a kind of
truck transactionization of the
disciplination I would include it yeah
so the issue you have with
discretization is detailed about
um so if you want to try to discretize
this
um would would you lose lose track of
how to how to maintain detail about
the questions
I mean everything would have to be
approximately yeah but I mean you could
just discretize it and put in all the
episodes
yes exactly that's exactly right
okay
so on the previous time you mentioned
but I don't get
um how different is this from the state
of affairs
or is that the album ah all right so
you can think of this as a way of
algorithmically imitating the best or
constructing all the essential
functionality of
that and okay
um
yes
lack of clarity for the mixing time is
as yes so mixing time is always hard and
if you it's similar to the class coaches
in some cases you can prove it but in
many cases
but I mean I could also just simulate
the path by doing the sludge I feel
about space them right yeah so
indeed so you can just say well I know
the physicists have been doing the right
thing let me just kind of see him later
hold that
but it requires a lot of the best
Academy is really large
sample usually is quite small and the
bath is really large so if you want to
do that it works but it's quite
expensive
but the point here is that you really
just distill the thing you want and
reduce it to a very thin setup like
series
so so you have a question so In
classical Monte Carlo if you talk to
practitioners so that that actually use
this
they they don't want to simulate the
buff at all they say that that this
doesn't work because like you want to
move on and see how what kind of you so
will come out of something you want to
do completely on the physical moves and
if they do this they get like 10 orders
of magnitudes
as opposed to simulating the bot so
exactly exactly so so that seems to be
like
so the reason why you don't want to do
what you want to to do yeah yeah so
depends on what you want if you just
want to simulate what business seems
then you can say oh let's just try to
see like
that I don't care about deep State
because I just want to imitate what I'm
doing
it you can also just say I want to keep
safe what's the best way of doing it
I take inspiration from nature but I
upgrade you
yes yep it could just get that like much
better
okay but I understood that you said that
you want to do simulated box that you're
effectively opening is like about
all right
is like
it seems to be working so we borrow it
improve it
I think the point is that you have
questions
because you could choose to represents
the exactly the physical path
so so the people that use this they they
have to do very non-mobile moves and
only then
yeah so you have to do very non-local
things and you could include that yeah
okay
that depends on
the problems like that in some cases is
possible
and we've been discussing it on my
discussions
um
so we designed algorithm our goal is to
basically pick the right set of embodian
operators
and it's been like right now it's not
very obvious why this has all kinds of
properties but it is your task as a
designer of algorithm to pick the right
one
so here's the main result of today is
the most technical slide
today we present on the content version
of classical markets
or Quantum Cube sampler
here's a statement
for any hamiltonian
and qubits and any desirable choice of
temperature inverse temperature beta
and some set of jumps
okay so given that we construct a
limbladian
L which is a continuous time Quantum
walk on a Markov chain
with the following desirable properties
first the Keepsake is stationary
state I'm sorry we don't know we don't
know that's super important
so that was bad
um but but we don't have one country yes
so it's a question that now we can
answer it on say 100 like 10 qubits by
doing numerics
unique or not
are this what does the numeric suggest
that it's Unique
in some cases it's fairly unique
sometimes we have four different specs
points so yeah lots of things are
happening and we don't we haven't quite
know what what is because it's all new
we don't we don't have experience
uniqueness sorry I mean this is a you
know uniqueness is a binary property so
something being fairly unique I don't
know what that means oh it could be like
there um
so if you wait a long time they actually
indirectly but if you wait only for sure
time they're like several minutes have
stable States okay but there is a quote
on version of detailed balance no you
can't do it yeah that's why we're using
it that's what we're using that's how we
design the algorithm
but that is unique if it's angotic and
it satisfying detailed balance it's
Unique yeah paragonic is we don't know
how to always make it
so what's the relationship between the
dumps
right I think so in classical you choose
a set of jumps and all those jumps you
construct a Markov chain
right and um
so it's a parameter of the algorithm if
we choose the wrongs incorrectly then
you might just not able to Traverse the
landscape in some like in some sense
but it's something I would go into early
blood depends on this job
so sort of implementing those jumps
yeah it will take a jump and then dress
it by some Quantum algorithm
value so it's kind of complicated it
depends on the previous things
all right
do nothing
yeah so you probably have more stringent
conditions than than just uh
not naturally it shows the junk to be
single-sized for maybe like two body
first
so there's some classical I mean you can
kind of borrow a lot of people doing in
Costco and they're trying to just do it
here
I think you do
um but we do have the construction and I
think in numeric system seems at least
not doing completely stupid things so
it's the right way to think about the
required key that it's probably some
increasing function of beta so if I
wanted to just write simulation time
only as a function of data it would be
super linear but we don't know what it
is
yeah so
based on classical intuition
if you want to go very low temperature
usually gets harder
what is this when beta gets largest it
gets harder sometimes get really really
hard
um sometimes it doesn't increase as fast
as
okay so it just depends on the case but
in general low temperature is harder
it is so this efficiency doesn't mean
efficiency because there's a mixing time
no idea if that is close to the
executive
yeah just think about Monte Carlo people
don't know how long it's going to mix
but a few steps
your local operators satisfy some
stuff
so for example
well I think you've been probably
apologize
by the way is some Physics assumption
that
can make your library much easier but
mathematically
thank you
especially when it comes to the second
condition which is that you can
efficient signal with blood yet and here
in the cost and it only takes very few
resettable and silos
and a hamiltonian simulation timeline
scale with t and beta
either let's try to understand what this
means
um you only needs very few and Silas
which means that you can replace a whole
big bath by a few things that you can
control
okay that's what this algorithm achieves
and the hamiltonian simulation time
scaling TN beta is we think it's
essentially optimal because there's
individually it's optimal for either t
or beta
it seems really hard to get Beyond this
this product
all right I guess can I ask about that
like if I have a note if I know what the
mixing time is
or are you saying that preparing the
give state is probably optimal and use
beta or they've simulating
um
right so here I thought I don't care
about mixing time which is like this
black box problem okay same with login
okay thanks
what is the main result but there are
lots of one I haven't had time to show
you um we've in a paper we basically
established a lot of Frameworks to
analyze this which
um directly applies to other problems
such as other limbladians coming from
the system so it's like a physical setup
we also can prove similar results
um and the more algorithmic side result
is that we also we also be able to
produce the purified Cube state so this
the whole thing becomes very Quantum so
it's like another layer of quantization
and can get this purified give state in
your Quantum memory
okay
let's take a um an intuitive
understanding of what's going on uh it's
very similar to a random mock so if you
go to energy basis um you can think of
some blob of probabilities as we move
around
but because of energy uncertainty
um there's some coherences at nearby
Energies
because you can't distinguish them so
they would just it could just remain
coherent
okay so there's two effects of mixing
one of them is incoherent which is more
classical you're removing things around
um but there also is coherent mixing
that because we cannot distinguish
energy
and so you see they're both classical
and content effects that's driving the
markup chain which make it interesting
very less
um we enforce detail balance so that the
fixed point is still a cube stage
all right so when you apply these jumps
it may not increase entropy you could
just rotate the states around
your parts I could increase your
enthalpy because your products that
don't
so this is just intended to be very
intuitive
um so if you look at our generator at
the space domain is actually very nice
so let's consider lattice hamiltonian
with single side jumps
then our algorithm actually simplify to
a sum of local and audience
where each individually fix the give
state
well at the same time they're all local
and the size of this jump is just beta
in other words if you want constant
temperature gives it this is locally
blood in that
um
that gives you the keep state
as a baseball
Services
because I mean it's a global property
so you can you repeat the question all
right so the question is what do I mean
by
um these things preserve the Deep state
so it's just this equation so if you've
been in a keep State and you attack on
this it Keepsake is enough
so there could be a lot of other states
that also understand what you mean by
this yeah it's very unintuitive so I was
asking if there's some intuition because
being in a gypsy is not a local property
somehow right
yeah so the intuition is a digital
balance can be implemented local
it's like saying it's just station free
exactly that's how it sounds to me which
is like exactly exact place exactly oh
sorry yeah first question
require interact
yes just use the icon argument
s
sorry and so every so every new modern
drums
right I'm just importing the intuitive
meaning of this in the hamiltonian case
and put it here
I think yeah
I think the God doesn't like write down
accounts
all right so to be very precise to be
very precise you can view this debate as
a operator
linear operator then the keep say is
actually the ground statement of that
I think you have two types
I mean it's not positive
ly you actually have to make it um you
have to take you can take the
discriminant you have to assimilarity
transformation
then it becomes like permission yeah but
I know is that there's examples of first
stage coming sorry about this
conversation from other states and then
you have to find the way to map this
back to density operators right
and which are several states of local
hypotonics
that's completely Unity of that that
actually works right yeah
which is not accountable
I mean so that's why this is interesting
I guess this whole like prosperity and
local all comes out
I mean this is a realization we have
again do you have examples which are not
concluded it sounds like it has no no no
no so you can take our construction a
little Guardian it has this property
but it's very general Construction it
always happens okay
for any hamiltonian real Construction
and construction that will have this
property yes so given that is
hamiltonian
this is required
I guess you have two types of locality
and one is the local jump which is a
truly local like yeah
and the other types of locality is
through the local which can be used
so how large is the support does it
depend on your energy resolution the
energy resolution is roughly Visa our
University okay so it's basically the
the radius is linear in your energy yes
it's perfect
too is an exclusive construction right
it's a
um
depends on the time I might try to skip
those I don't I don't even have to go
through them I don't have I don't say
too much on those because it's just kind
of technical
so so for example
okay
[Laughter]
yes also in that case
instructions maybe it was not satisfied
some of them
so so it is
um
it depends on the choice of the job
so
can you give you some insight about
seeing what's operating or you know
I haven't thought about it
okay
so have another questions more physical
right so if you look at the relaxation
in the hitbox it's not first principle
so if you use latitude simulation that's
fine but it is
implementation you know you draw a
physical state from say Jeep's
distribution I'm not even sure you know
you Union native relaxation process
we're working with variety
because it does look at thermodynamics
right
so
I don't have data to explain the
question explain it the question like
you can say oh I'm running this
artificial algorithm how does computer
things actually happen in nature it's
not very clearly different that's right
yes
even you deluminate the perfect everyday
relaxation you make it fast
I mean this is all just models I mean
before this model something that can
make mathematical sense and capture as
much as possible of the model but model
could be very dirty
so the other question started
convergence in small
ER say you have a distribution right
it's not a perfect distribution
um
how far YouTube's distributes
all right you couldn't say you can ask
like oh can I just get something
that could happen
um
all sorts of ways to approximate this
algorithm what kind of relax that like
the the thing you want like if you
really want to keep state in like Trace
distance this is how we set up but you
can relax it to me anyways
all right so let me just add one comment
that I know lots of people I really love
ground state they don't like thermostat
as much so you can also apply this to a
ground States if it's camped and the
cost
um just amounts to setting this beat out
to be one over the gap
and they're very log dependencies
so intuition here is that in order to
know that you're getting lower energy in
particular that you're going to the
ground state you sort of need to resolve
energy scale of the gap
and that's not all you need to pay so
that this one over Gap is going to
enlarge each of these blood of limb
Guardians
yeah yeah I I dropped those in this
Omega Toyota
so in complexity login is quite
important but just physically I think
just put it here too
to emphasize is only depend only depends
physically on a gap
the comment that it's going to make to
delete earlier it's not enough to just
that you can have
a constant Gap is still MP hard
mixing time
yeah yeah right mixing time exactly
right the mixing time and intensity of
States so here I'm
um the reason why you actually get a
login factor is because the freak slider
Stadium like n of them usually if you're
more of them well then
and then that this will have to change
but even stay preparation same problem
yeah it's classical yes
prepare it if you have if you have a
constant
uh
finally it does
to prepare it with a constant overlap
though I mean with phase estimation
density of states
thank you
so most most systems
right so for example if you just take
classical icing model and it has
basically of this hold down the mixing
time is blocks
so you don't get a good stage yeah it
happens
and then at a time you might just change
your goal as well I just want one of
them then it still works
question
but if you have lots of symmetry then it
could be lots of states as stationary
that has the station now there will be
the fixed point and and that's fine it's
a feature of the model you can try to
break it by choosing a property set of
transition that breaker symmetry
then it would change so
lots of like different situations but
for this you need uh
updates
um
I haven't looked at it in full detail
but I believe the Symmetry argument will
also apply to this
okay
also so that that was the claim of the
theorem now let me try to explain what
is supposed to be powerful what's new
here
um so the secret sauce of our recipes is
continuous rewinding
so it appears that instead of doing the
script rejection
which I've been discussed with audience
somehow doing this continuously just
make your life 100 times better
really 100 is
actually accurate actual actual thing it
just makes everything possible I think
it makes the map like possible to be
presented
to discuss huh
and yeah and so sometimes when you do it
um
it becomes even more simpler so like on
the left hand side you have to go back
and if you first go there and then you
kind of go kick it back and you're also
epsilons and they'll kind of make you
miserable
but here what you instead do
um is to just wait for the continuous
transitions
so if there could be different many
different jumps and you just want to put
different weights on it
if the one that you don't like to put a
very small weight the ones that you like
you pick a very big weight
and it effectively is doing rejection
continuously
in this comment that natural seems to be
nature seems to be doing this by
system-bath interaction
nature is continuous
and also justify what this seems to be
nice
and algorithmically to really do this
you have to use a lot of tricks like of
course like qft having simulation and
some weak measurements and this big
measurement is especially for doing this
continuous
yourself
right which is why you jump through it
you're you know wanting me you don't you
don't just just decide to leave you
you've got to know what you are there
um
I do not have a very good explanation
isn't just becomes extremely Direct
operator and then say Oh I want this to
have this coefficient
and then there's like black box and body
simulation that allows you to do this
so I don't have to have a very nice
intuitive explanation
it just seems that we need to rejection
things there's so many elevated things
that come out of it
also I want to give explanation of life
is powerful
um so In This Very in this three level
examples where California has zero plus
one and minus one
um and let's suppose we do a jump a that
it maps to plus one and minus one
and let's see what's going to happen in
our algorithm if we implement this
um in average the hamiltonian energy is
actually doesn't change
however
um they're part of transition that
increase the energy and also the one
that
um not just say you have three level
zero plus one yeah
three states
yeah and then if you apply algorithm
what's going to do is to punish this
transition that's going upwards
and then it's going to favor
depending going downwards
so then it actually realizes certain
kind of hamiltonian gradient descents
that you don't get to go up you can go
down
and it would just have this transition
going down and they wait a while it
becomes the negative one state
remarkably this does not require any
post selection this is really the power
of rewinding because whenever you
whenever the state wants to go up say no
stay there
um some of this idling make it very very
nice
so in other words you can actually
repeat this process if you have
hamiltonian lots of levels you're not
losing any probability so you just keep
going down
there's no hidden exponential factor in
these
algorithms
with this slide so are you saying that
this is the idea in your mind what
you're doing or yeah this is to
illustrate what happens you run
algorithm
um with a hamiltonian it has three
levels and a jump that does this
and just illustrate how the energy gets
lower
it's because it put punishment on
increasing energy
thank you
this is the greatest level this is also
what the Metropolis are working with it
yes yes because it's all discrete so
this you can actually do this
so this is the gradient of
age with respect to a kind of
H with respect to top opinion you want
to choose the objective function which
is simultaneous and now you're changing
things according to a
and this this our algorithm isolates the
transition that
um decrease the energy with respect to
Hamilton
how do you see that this is the gradient
of that okay
this is just some words I've described
it so this is what the what that means
an example of the construction for this
example
they can take the hamiltonian to be
through that
yeah
yeah yeah
I'm eager to see the construction
Maybe
possible example isn't it which aspect
of this example
right so to make it really content you
can make energy levels like really
continuous
thank you
let me choose the wrong example
they just keep going man
um
all right so here's unfortunately
another classical hamiltonian that's
illustrate at least what this is doing
um is that the fact that is preserving
probability
um save you from
other problem
so suppose you want to prepare the
ground state of this guy in the
classical argentonian it's all zero can
you start with the initial state that
has little overlap
all right so it's overlap is something
is something that people have constantly
discussed
um
and if you just do imagine time
Evolution this actually kills the
algorithm because the overlap is so
small
however because our Amazon preserved
possibility
um it only takes a very short mixing
time to get to the ground stage
so you immediately see that there's some
qualitative difference happening
I think at this point
understanding the algorithms
okay okay so let me let me okay
all right so what do you know
so here it is
um
we're going to isolate transitions by
the energy changes
If energy increase reduces energy
decreases
so we received choose this involving
operator to be something look like this
so it's some scalar times a matrix
this would be collection of or the value
operators
all right so what is this a
um this a is
um
right so what is a is some Matrix that
have some that's some there's some
Matrix and then we look at it at the
energy basis so there's like a matrix so
here PSI and PSI J two different axes
and then return lots of entries
and what you want to do here is to
select only
the transitions with
um energy difference Omega
so start with the Matrix could be really
large but you just cut out everything
else and just keep this tiny bit
so this is a way to select the eighth
well this is the way to construct a
Omega AutoPage
so you're given a set of jumps a yes and
now you're constructing a filtered
version of a okay
which throw away lots of transitions
treatment and the reason why I do that
is that all of these have very similar
energy changes
but they are also in the local they're
awfully not local executives
um well depends on how how um how how
precise you want to be so there's
actually like an energy window you can
choose like the resolution if the
resolution is very very good it's really
non-vocal but if it's not perfect it
actually could still be focused
I'm talking to you that this is really
construct
but in any picture it's very clear that
okay you want the jump to change energy
by disability
and once you have this assuming you have
this
you just multiply by the appropriate
ways
but in all this if if you had a way of
identifying their energy precisely and
you then would have done the discrete
thing as well you could have done it
this way
somewhere in here you're going to say
why this gets around the
knowledge yes yes yeah so the the very
technical thing is that there's a
uncertainty Omega
uh uncertainty like some window of
uncertainty and then that makes you
reject like discrete rejection like
awful
but here um
if you just look at this guy and then
just plug in building value and it
defines the limb body
it doesn't have to think about rejection
anymore you just you just have a
Limbaugh then you just have the same way
but in the construction you're happy
with Delta being Constance or or a fixed
thing like you're not taking it too no
so you don't have to do something again
that's the remarkable thing oh so the
points I keep saying is actually kind of
smooth the smoothness that Keepsake is
really bitter
and that's kind of always here
so again
like like very high Precision it's like
more apps
it effectively it's exact um
dependent so it's not one of them
computer
so where are the gamma's coming
because you first had this converter
content objects and then you kind of
when you know the energy you can't just
apply like a classic kind of like weight
just control weights up
you can choose them you just need to
have detailed Banks
right
um so how do you actually Implement
these like kind of Highly local like so
this weird physical thing that you
directly address the energy basis
um it actually has a very simple time
domain representation
it's just a Fourier transform
as we always need in Quantum algorithms
so what is this aft it's a Heisenberg
evolution of the operator a so it looks
like this
um this is actually something that's
very physical this is it shows on in
physics every day
and then if you write it out they
actually just naturally has this
exponential
e i minus EJ expression
because you're on one side you have plus
h on the either side you have negative h
and initially diagnosis how the energy
is changing
so
you're working in the energy basis yes
how do I get those energy states in
practice all right so yeah so this is
the way of representing the Matrix
but this is the one that it actually
implements this is perfectly physical
okay
the a is some simple operator like
single parties
and your sandwich it with hamiltonian
evolution
must be Heisenberg above that
uh there's other than to like Implement
data
computers
right so you need some some circuits so
it's next slide so actually have to do
something like look like this so you
have two-sided Control San Antonio
Evolution you put some weights and you
do it
so in some sense not too different from
Place estimation but I mean as
it has similar kind of ingredients but
let's just appeared to be the right way
of doing it the toast is different under
this Quantum has over sampling because
that's exactly the same thing here well
I mean there's lots of technical
differences that make
algorithm
so intuitively yeah you're just
measuring energies and then put the
weights at the right kind of
um
energy Trend like including this is
similar but technically it is to
implement business we actually take a
lot of time to think about this
so what there's wrong
so where does the French is not
technically but in terms of he tried to
do
um the other description what lessons
um
so there's one very technical assumption
that we find
to be impossible like maybe you can just
change it take a look at the subject and
still work I mean it seems some various
like super power version of phase
yeah so there's some a physical version
of face estimation and then like maybe
you can remove them and still make
Amazon work but now we don't know
with extreme accuracy or something
extreme boosted
but like um
energies is something to drink to mesh
voice that clear some non-blue fit parts
you can have something that's having
like highly precise in bands of energy
across the cross points
so it could be a technical problem that
couldn't solved but
um
is it possible to give an example before
this slide
um
like take this and show how the very
Central
zero one two one minus one zero is it
possible
how this looks in this case
um well this a Omega would just be
selecting
if you cancel this a minus will be just
one of the jumps one of the a omegas
because this has energy difference
negative one you select that thing and
then put away from that there's the a
minus is already you don't have to do
the filtering there okay you do the
filtering plus and a minus oh yeah
because of the screen is discreet thing
is
so let's continue as well uh things got
close here basically you know
um
so it's very important that you can kind
of incoherently address those
all right then you can say I don't want
this trial
okay
um if you think this prescription and do
it for a classical walk yeah
um for classical uh continuous swap then
you get you get the natural thing
um you could if you choose everything
correctly you do nothing you could have
like a contour problem like all these
things and you only flip X
then it reduces the classical case if
you start with in Hangouts
but it's always in technical State no
one knows what happens
we don't know if
we don't
go back
to the AAS you choose uh in order to be
you think that you put in the circuit
that are they related to the local jobs
that you started
yeah yeah
X and you could run
yeah
because
yeah so you synthesize
Finance energy you could only measure
energies of a certain position but it
seems like you have the same problem
here all right so here um
you can actually make this completely
um yeah I can put a lot of registered
here so this Omega part is actually
microphone energy process so right so
discount very technical but what reset
your resolution is the hydronium
simulation
you could have like a continuous
representative
but each of them actually has each of
them is smeared out
so there are actually two different
energies you're talking about so
Omega that's scrolling around
however there's this energy uncertainty
so if you only change in makeup a little
bit this operator doesn't change that
much
so the fundamental resolution is this
parameter but not how many omegas you
choose
which is a little technical but the
but this this goes into it
and in simple cases
excited
in America we see that it could be like
four metastable states but after if you
wait a little longer they'll they'll
collapse
because in small systems that I think
everything is quite unique
trying to understand what's Fine's
uniqueness yeah
oh unique let's just refers like whether
there's only one stationary space yeah I
know like what's foreign
symmetry is one one cosmotic
um or if the system is actually very
classy there are lots of kind of it's
hard to Traverse a landscape
so then it's
you know because it makes in time to
really long
we could just because you can't have you
can have actually unique ground state
unique uh stationary State a lot of
states that have very small Gap they
take a really long time for them to mix
fully it's still unique but it's do you
just have it it's physically yeah
um
this could be sunrise today we get the
algorithm that prepares the cube State
uh in small Nicole fashion
um it's satisfied the two to drive the
features
um of Monte Carlo that's efficient and
correct and and I have not talked too
much about this uniqueness but in
practice is quite important
and a cost is
um just go with the mixing time
so let me end with opportunities
um for those who are still interested in
this topic
um
So In classical Monte Carlo ever since
this invention there have been so much
research in the past few decades and
here
I argue that we're in some kind of
similar positions because now you have
this content markup chain you can ask
all sorts of questions that people ask
classical
mixing times can ask how do what happens
if I apply to optimization problem how
this algorithm compare the existing
algorithm
um there is so many things that we don't
we don't understand
um now we're just doing like very small
scale numerics and see what's going on
it's already have some nice kind of
scientific
um
understanding
and I'd like to end just by saying that
well maybe
um give sampling could be the first
useful Quantum algorithm because it
seems that consumation really requires
this initial State preparation so Maybe
this could be really useful as well
thanks for
staying
[Applause]
Matrix
or hyper Matrix form
Ula
does it mean the quantum one or any of
them
I didn't mean to extend detail balanced
but like
in the classical case not a unique way
to get
get like give States
um I haven't told a few people out there
but now we just use details it was
somehow is nice
so like this is generalized world you
know it can use conjecture or like
provided intuition as a comment um oh
um
so if you if you wanted to make your
bath kind of more exotic I don't know if
this would apply because usually in an
open system
um people just assume the bath is
extremely nice like almost like all
sorts of like Fast properties uh you
change the path I think becomes
independent
yeah
use of the word the first useful I mean
deliberately chosen to be provocative
yeah this is like helpful you know
because this construction uses
hamiltonian simulation
example
[Laughter]
thank you
so thank you for your walk it was very
interesting I was just going to ask you
if you do happen to work out an example
okay even the example
I'm going to be here for a couple more
weeks I think other people would also
want to see it and it might be
interesting to just give the talk in a
way where you're focusing on that
example
because it was a little bit hard for me
to understand what you're actually uh
I think some other people would it could
be kind of interesting for us too
going on to what he was saying with this
first Quantum algorithm it'll give you
an opportunity maybe to count the
resources
because all these are ongoing so I
apologize because we're just trying to
distill you know we start somewhere in
some 15 no 15 page paper and try to like
make this simplest input and
thanks again for bearing with me
all right thank you
[Applause]
is
that okay